LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O.
This is our last session on
the evening for day one.
Louis Gray here, with my
co-moderator Daniel Sieberg,
who has returned.
Thank you very much.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Happy
to be here.
LOUIS GRAY: And Greg
DeMichillie, from the Cloud
Platform team, is a Director
of Product
Management on Cloud.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Hey, guys.
LOUIS GRAY: And cloud has had a
really solid update here at
Google I/O, a lot of
good information.
And so we wanted to take this
time at the end of day one to
really walk through those
updates and understand from
you, what's going on with cloud
at Google, and what do
people need to know?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Sure.
Well, as you mentioned, it was
a pretty big day for us here.
When I think about what we're
doing in the cloud at Google,
it really comes back to the
fact that over the past 14
years at Google, we've been
building this amazing
infrastructure for
our own use.
And whether people knew it or
not when they used Maps and
Gmail and Search, they've been
using this incredible
infrastructure.
But until now, it's been
something that's only
available for Googlers.
And now with the cloud, we're
actually letting third-party
developers, any developer out
there, run their applications
on this same world-class
infrastructure.
And I think that's probably
the biggest,
most exciting thing.
About 11 months ago, we were
here at Google I/O when we
first launched the
Cloud Platform.
And it's been a busy 11
months since then.
We launched, I think something
like 163 new features in the
11-month period, which is
really phenomenal if
you think about it.
But that's because we get
to build on top of this
incredible infrastructure that
already exists within Google.
So I then look at and think
about what we actually
announced here.
There's sort of a couple
big issues.
The biggest one is probably
Compute Engine.
For folks who know, Compute
Engine is our infrastructure
as a service product.
It allows people to run virtual
machines running
operating systems of their
choice in our infrastructure.
And as of today, as of, in fact,
about 40 minutes ago,
it's live and open for sign-ups
for any developer.
So any developer out there
who wants to can go to
cloud.google.com, and sign-up,
and start firing up virtual
machines and playing with
what we can do in the
infrastructure.
So that's probably the single
biggest announcement.
We also talked quite a
bit about App Engine.
And again, for people who have
been using the Cloud Platform,
they know that App Engine is
a platform as a service.
Basically, it allows developers
to concentrate
their code on the part that
makes their app different.
And to not write that
boilerplate code that just
makes sure that it scales up
when I get traffic and scales
down when I don't get traffic.
App Engine handles all that.
App Engine's been usable for
Java and Python and Go.
And we announced today that
we're adding PHP to the mix,
which we think is a pretty big
move in terms of millions of
developers out there who now
can use App Engine without
having to learn a
new language.
LOUIS GRAY: And so PHP is one of
those things that comes up.
Why PHP?
Why are we doing that now?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah.
I mean, that one's actually
pretty easy.
If you look at any of the
statistics out there, three
quarters of the world's websites
are powered in some
form by PHP.
So it's just incredibly
widely used.
And so that made it a real
obvious target for us.
We really wanted to take
and not just build
your father's PHP.
So we wanted to take PHP, which
people know and love,
but bring to it the App Engine
magic, which lets you build
websites that scale up much
faster than with any other
technology.
And equally important, when
there's no traffic, we scale
everything down to zero and you
have absolutely no charge
when there's no traffic.
LOUIS GRAY: Excellent.
And one thing I noticed-- and
Daniel and I were talking
about it earlier, which is
probably where he was going--
when we look in the keynote,
where cloud started to be part
of the announcements from the
other teams, and two parts in
particular.
One, we were looking at Android,
where we talked about
Google Cloud Messaging and the
sheer volume of updates that
are happening every single day
with applications on Android.
And the second piece was
Google+, talking about using a
Google data center as your
dark room for photos.
And I think what I'm hearing
from them and from yourself is
this real abstraction of where
the data actually is and
putting the data
center to work.
Maybe you can talk about that,
about how the Cloud Platform
is really benefiting the other
platforms here at Google.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: It all
comes back to the
fact that at Google--
to do the amazing things we do
at Google, we've had to invent
new technology.
We've had to invent new data
center technology.
We've had to invent new file
systems with things like GFS.
And what people don't
even understand is--
LOUIS GRAY: And that's
Google File System.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Google
File System.
2002, 2004, we wrote these
papers that really changed the
way data centers are run.
What people don't realize is
at Google, we've actually
already moved a generation
beyond those.
We actually now use even more
powerful technology on our
infrastructure.
I think what you're seeing
across Google is--
whether it's in Google+, whether
it's in Android or in
the cloud, it's all helping
customers and developers do
things that they never
could do before.
And in the Cloud Platform, very
few people could afford
to build the kind of data
structures we--
data centers we can.
I'll give you one example--
networking.
Everybody knows how important
networking is to application
performance.
At Google, we led a partnership
that actually is--
we are the only non-ISP to
have laid submarine cable
under the ocean, across
the Pacific Ocean.
And we did that because
high-quality networking
bandwidth is critical to
our core products.
And what we're doing
with cloud is now--
other developers can just come
along for the ride and get the
advantages of the networking,
and the performance, and the
data centers we're doing.
And I think you see that
across Google, that the
investments that we've made in
infrastructure pay off across
the whole company.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Now, for people
who aren't here at I/O,
they may not know that there's
actually a cloud--
we're part of the cloud, in a
sense, right here because of
the data sensing experiment
that's going on.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah.
DANIEL SIEBERG: And in fact,
there's one just below our
feet right now.
Talk a little bit about what
that is here at I/O, what are
we learning from that?
What is it all about?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah,
this is cool.
One of the things we wanted to
do was we wanted to build a
real-world example of the Cloud
Platform, and we wanted
it to be part of
Moscone Center.
So all across Moscone Center,
there's 525 of
these little sensors.
And they are running open source
Arduino processors,
open source software.
And they're collecting data on
things like the humidity, and
the temperature, and the noise
level, which is a little
quieter now than it was
a few minutes ago.
But you can imagine when
tracks are out.
So we're measuring just the
ambient information about the
volume and the temperature.
And there's pressure
mats counting how
many people walk by.
Now, you can imagine there's
525 of these collecting
multiple data streams
per second.
And we're all funneling that
into a Google Cloud Platform
application.
And we're collecting that
data and using App
Engine to ingest it.
We're using Compute Engine to
do some analysis for it.
We're using our big data
products to allow people to
query it and visualize it.
And if people come over to the
sandbox over here, they can
actually explore and visualize
some of this data and see,
where were the popular places
that people were hanging out?
Where and when was
it really noisy?
And again, this is all done in
a way that when we're done,
the data's all going to be
turned over to the community
in the tools so that people can
continue to examine and
look at this data.
So I think it's just a really
cool example of the physical
world meeting the Cloud Platform
in a way that allows
developers to really see a truly
large-scale application.
LOUIS GRAY: You mentioned
big data.
It's a term that gets
thrown around a lot.
You had an announcement today,
which was Cloud Datastore.
Maybe you can walk us through
that and help us understand
how it fits with the other
storage options
that are out there?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah, that's
a great example.
The Cloud Datastore--
let me back up for a second.
At Google, if you think about
it, we've had to build
technologies with very big
databases and data sets to do
things like search the web.
And from the beginning, we knew
that SQL databases were
just not going to cut it.
So we've built what is probably
the world's largest
NoSQL data store for our
own use at Google.
And we had previously made that
available just through
App Engine.
And to give you a sense of the
scalability of this, this data
store in App Engine is currently
processing 4 and 1/2
trillion requests per month.
Not billion, trillion
requests per month.
And the big news now is that
data store is now not just
available from App Engine,
it's available
from Compute Engine.
Or actually, any place
with a REST API.
So any developer, no matter
what programming language
you're using or environment
you're in, you now have access
to this incredibly
high-performance, highly
scalable data store.
And we think that's also a big
step forward because NoSQL
databases really are at the
heart of a lot of modern,
highly scalable web
applications.
I don't think people understand
when we say Google
scale, what we mean.
We count in trillions,
not billions.
LOUIS GRAY: And trillions--
the joke would be, I've
forgotten how
to count that low.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Right.
Even Carl Sagan would call a
trillion a big number, right?
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
And you were saying what it
can do for our partners.
What are some interesting
implementations that you've
already seen with
Cloud Datastore?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah, so
there's a couple really good
examples of the Cloud
Platform.
A couple have been
around mobile.
Not surprisingly, there are
a lot of people out there
building mobile applications.
And almost any application, you
immediately need to have
some sort of a back end, whether
it's a game because
you want to connect people
together, or whether you just
want to collect information
about what features are being
used or not.
Any mobile application worth
its salt has a back end.
So some of the examples we've
seen are FreshPlanet, which is
a company that makes a mobile
app called SongPop, which I
don't know if you've seen.
You challenge your friends and
it will play little snippets
of a pop music--
it's in different categories--
and the first one to identify
the song wins.
They currently are built
on App Engine.
And they're really proud to say
that they have only two
developers who built their back
end of the application,
despite the application
scaling up and being--
I think the fifth most popular
application in the store.
Another one that's really
popular right now, for any of
our viewers who are in Europe,
they might know that the
Eurovision Song Contest
is going on right now.
The Song Contest is very big in
Europe, and part of it is
voting on what song should
be the best.
What we've done is they've built
the Eurovision back end
on top of Compute Engine.
And so they're seeing
peak loads of
50,000 requests a second--
peak loads.
And we're able to meet that, and
90% of those we deliver in
under 24 millisecond latency.
So think about that.
At peak, we're delivering the
vast majority of their
requests in 24 milliseconds
or less.
LOUIS GRAY: And what's
interesting about that is,
first, we're talking big numbers
with trillions, and
now we're talking about little,
tiny numbers, like
microseconds.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah.
LOUIS GRAY: And trying to work
even smaller than that.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Absolutely.
One of things that we've really
tried at Google is we
know that speed matters.
So we've tried really hard in
the Cloud Platform to focus on
not just fast performance,
but consistency.
Because it's very frustrating
if you're building an
application and one day your
data performance is just fine
and the next day it seems
to be slow, and you
can't figure out why.
So it's really been sort of a
hallmark of ours to think
about not just raw performance,
but consistency
of performance as well.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Louis touched on
big data, and I would love
to hear from you on what are
the sort of secrets to
unlocking big data?
What are companies doing to
kind of make that useful?
Because people talk about it a
lot, but I think that a lot of
people struggle with really what
to do with what it means.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: The hard part
of big data really comes
in a couple forms.
One is just the sheer size
of the data means that
traditional database management
tools just don't work.
You need to think about the
data in a different way.
And clearly, that's where things
like NoSQL data stores,
the Cloud Datastore come in.
But the other thing about big
data is a lot of it is about
how you aggregate different
data from
different sources together.
It's how do I take my log data
and how do I combine that with
my user data?
And how do I combine that
with my sales data?
And do it in a way that lets
a casual business analyst
actually make sense of it.
And that's where things
like BigQuery come in.
BigQuery is our product that
allows you to, almost
magically, take these giant
NoSQL databases and query them
as though they were SQL.
You write SQL-like queries as
though it were a SQL database,
but underneath it's, in fact,
automatically sharding and
it's a highly scalable
NoSQL infrastructure.
So I think that the challenges
of big data really come in
multiple dimensions.
But mostly it comes back to
people wanting a platform that
takes care of the grunt work,
for lack of a better word.
I mean, there's a lot of work in
building up big data that's
not unique to your data set.
And we're really trying to
take that away, so that
developers get to focus on the
fun part, if you will.
The things that make their app
different rather than the
things that make their app the
same as somebody else.
LOUIS GRAY: And I'm glad
you mentioned BigQuery.
One cool thing about Google
Developers Live is we don't
just start and stop at I/O. We
have Google Developers Live
events year-round.
And we regularly have guests,
like Michael Manoochehri from
your team, to go ahead
and come in
and talk about BigQuery.
And you mentioned
that it's fun.
And there's something fun about
seeing somebody take a
big data set, be it Wikipedia
or something of that order,
and running a query against
it and seeing
those real-time results.
So I've enjoyed watching that as
we've done our GDL events.
And so one thing you also talked
about, without giving
any secrets away--
I don't want [INAUDIBLE] to come
over here and get us all
in trouble.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Thank you.
I appreciate that.
LOUIS GRAY: But you
talked about the
uniqueness of Google.
And you said sometimes we're
working on the next generation
of a file system or any other
piece of your equipment that
people haven't even thought
of or caught up to yet.
What is it that's unique about
the Google environment that
gives you access to incredible
delivery?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: I think if
you step back, we invented
everything we invented
because we had to.
Google has big goals.
When Google set out to say,
we're going to index the
entire world wide web, that
means you need to store an
entire copy of the
world wide web.
And you quickly realize that
normal file systems
don't work for that.
So you have to invent your
own file system.
It really is a case of us
setting huge objectives--
having a Gmail system where
you can have 25
gigabytes of email.
Well, that makes you have to
invent new technology.
So I think that's one part of
the secret at Google, is that
we aim for big goals.
And as part of that, that
forces you to invent new
computer science and invent
new data centers.
And the other part is we invest
in our infrastructure.
One of the things--
[INAUDIBLE] said this in
the keynote, so I feel
like I can say it.
We spent $2.9 billion on
infrastructure last year.
That's a phenomenal
amount of money.
And we do that because it's so
critical to our own success.
We have to do it to be able to
keep advancing the state of
what we do.
And the Cloud Platform, we are
just really fortunate enough
to be able to take these amazing
things that Google
develops for its own use and
offer them up for other
developers to use.
And that's really where
the magic comes in.
I think it's fun to see
technologies that we develop
and to have us not just write
a public paper about it,
although we do that.
We continue to publish
academic papers.
But to go to the next step and
say, here's an academic paper.
And here's a running version
in Google Cloud that
you can play with.
I think that's pretty fun.
It's pretty amazing at Google.
So I really think it's the
combination of there's Google
big and Google scale, and
we aim for that in
everything we do.
And then in cloud, we get to
come along for the ride and
invite other developers
into the party.
So that's really a lot
of fun for me.
LOUIS GRAY: Earlier we
had the team on--
we call it Performance Alley.
The Chrome team came and
they talked about
making the web faster.
And one of the things that we
touched on is it's an old
adage that you don't really
solve a bottleneck, you just
move it somewhere else.
And you continue to find out
whether it's a computation, or
it's a server, or it's the
network, or it's the cloud.
And it seems like with the cloud
platform, a lot of the
work we're doing here at Google,
we abstract a lot of
that away from the developer.
So the developer doesn't
have to worry anymore.
How do you start that kind of
analysis and chase that
bottleneck so it continues
to move and
becomes less of an issue?
GREG DEMICHILLIE: No, you're
absolutely right.
Every time you make one area
faster, you now have-- there's
always one area that's at
the top of the stack--
the area you want to work
on most, right?
And that's the fun that as you
nail one area, then the bar
just keeps being
raised higher.
And I think that notion of
constantly chasing the next
performance metric is
really important.
In Compute Engine, for example,
as part of the
sign-ups we demonstrated
spinning up a thousand VMs--
or just a couple hundred VMs.
Don't want to oversell.
And our VMs are currently
starting up in the range of 20
to 30 seconds to sort
up in a VM.
When we talk to customers, they
say, oh, that's amazing.
That's phenomenal.
But we look at that and
go, OK, that's fine.
But that's not really
where we want to be.
And the reason is we really
want to change
the way people work.
An example--
one of the things we announced
today that I really think is
going to change the way people
think about cloud applications
is around--
this may sound mundane, but
it's around billing.
Today, with almost every cloud
provider, your time is
measured in hours.
So if you make a 15-minute
compute job,
you pay for an hour.
It's sort of like if I made a
phone call from 15 minutes and
the phone company charged
me for an hour.
That wouldn't be right.
Well, because our VMs start up
so fast, we actually charge by
the minute.
There's a 10-minute minimum.
But then after that, you
only pay for the
actual minutes you use.
And we think this really kind
of changes the way people
think about problems.
You can start to throw cores
at a problem, if you will.
Like, why not double the number
of cores and make the
job take 20 minutes instead
of 40 minutes?
Because now, I can do that.
And actually, it's cost
effective to do that.
So we think the performance, the
sub hour billing is going
to open up a lot of new ways for
people to use computing.
So that's probably, in the
non-product area, one of the
things I think is most
interesting and we're getting
a lot of good response for.
But you couldn't do that if we
didn't nail the startup time
and make the performance
really fast.
But you're right, so doing
performance in one area then
opens up new possibilities
in others.
DANIEL SIEBERG: I know we're
running out of time, but I
would love if you could
address the idea of
information security, which is
obviously something I'm sure
that you think about a lot.
But in terms of the ISO standard
that's applied to
managing data and all of that,
I think that's absolutely
worth talking about.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah.
So obviously, at Google, it's
critically important that we
have-- information security
is just a core part of
everything we do.
But what customers want is
they want some external
validation of that.
And the ISO standard
27001 is that.
They come through and they audit
your physical security
of your data centers, your
logical security, your access
control privileges.
They can come in and do audits
at various points and times.
And so we have now completed the
ISO 27000 certification on
App Engine, Compute Engine,
and cloud storage.
And one of the things we've
heard from, particularly some
of the larger customers, is that
it's a confidence sign.
And we're going to continue to
do more certifications as time
goes forward because we think
they're a good way of
demonstrating how important
security is and how seriously
we take it at Google.
But you're right, it's
foundational to the whole
notion of doing cloud
computing.
So I was really happy
that we did that.
And again, stepping back, it's
another example where we have
to invest in security
for our own
purposes, anyway, for Google.
And again, then the external
developers can just take
advantage of that.
So yeah, I was glad that we got
that and we were able to
announce that today.
DANIEL SIEBERG: That's great.
LOUIS GRAY: And I'm glad you
were able to join us.
I really appreciate you
waiting to do the
last slot of day one.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: No problem.
I'm in between the attendees
and I think
like food and drink.
So I appreciate the
chance to be here.
LOUIS GRAY: It's been
really exciting to
talk about Cloud Platform.
I mean, the kind of scale that
we have at Google is really
tremendous.
I'm really glad to see that
we're really taking that to
the development community.
One thing we do at GDL is we
talk to our developers every
day throughout the year, in
their language, in their time
zone, from a location
that makes sense.
We're real excited to
do that at I/O.
GREG DEMICHILLIE: Yeah.
And encourage developers
to try it
out and give us feedback.
We have product forums.
We have pre-release forums.
We have issue trackers.
We want to hear.
The PHP is a classic example.
PHP was partly driven by the
fact that we had direct
feedback from you just
saying we want this.
So we want to hear from people
about what's the next thing
that they would like
to see us do.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
Great.
Well, thank you so much.
Daniel Sieberg and I will be
back here tomorrow morning.
I'm really looking
forward to that.
We kick off our GDL at I/O
broadcasting even before the
sessions kick off tomorrow,
from 9:00 to 10:00 AM.
What we're going to be doing
is showcasing a lot of the
work you did in the sandboxes.
DANIEL SIEBERG: Exactly.
That's what I was doing for
the better part of this
afternoon, was wandering
around to different
sandboxes--
YouTube.
We talked to some folks about
Drive, Google+, and, of
course, Maps.
So we're going to bring all
of that to you tomorrow.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
So we're going to run through
those sandbox partners and we
have a really special treat.
We're going to have Bradley
Horowitz from Google+ to do a
deep dive around lunchtime
tomorrow for those of you in
the Pacific side.
So we welcome you coming back
and talking GDL at I/O.
In the meantime, subscribe to
Google Developers on YouTube.
You won't miss a single thing
from us throughout the year.
And check us out at
developers/google.com/live.
We'll see you tomorrow morning.